Speaker 1: One other but speaking of psychosis,
by the way, just one other thing. So many of
you wrote to me and told me, David, something
seems to have happened here with Mike Lindell,
also known as Mike Pillow in related to the
election because he's been doing some really,
really strange TV appearances where he seems truly
to have lost that. He claims he has all sorts of
people who are here or there or I don't even know
where. Yeah, it is weird. Here is a clip in which
Mypillow Mike Lindell from his airplane says
he is somehow monitoring every race for fraud.
Speaker 2: What we're going to be watching every
race. We're going to have the real time crime
disclosure, frank speech dot com.
Speaker 1: Is that real? Like,
what could they possibly be watching?
Speaker 2: You can watch me there tomorrow night.
We are tracking every race by cyber. I want
all the bad guys out there to know through
the Edison report. We are watching. And we
also have another way to watch what's going
on with the computers in the machine shop. I'm
putting them on notice, Steve. They're all on
notice that we are. By the way, you can turn
in after crime Dodd Frank speech dot com right.
Speaker 1: If you see any irregularities
you can report it to pillow.
Speaker 2: You see anything
turn it in there or yeah.
Speaker 1: And people say to me, David, is
that funny? Is that sad? Is it dangerous?
What exactly is that? Mike Pillow appeared.
Who the hell knows where? It's so difficult
to even understand where these appearances are
happening. This is something called victory. I
don't even know what this is. Here, he says, you
know, he's catching people red handed. This was
as the election results were coming in last night.
Speaker 2: I want to bring in Mike Lindell. Mike,
you got some interesting results you wanted to
share. Go ahead. Yeah, well, first of all, when
you guys were talking before, I was listening to
who who attacked our country and what is this all
about? Right. It's the CCP, the Union Party, the
deep state, the globalists, and now the Democrat
Party joining with all of globalist. Here's what
we have in our real time crime desk. If you have
a graphic to put up, I'm going to show you just
one of them. And this is from the Democrat.
So we're watching these races. Vance was.
Speaker 1: What did you I don't even know
what that was. I mean, but that
graphic he put up meant nothing.
Speaker 2: Vance was one. I believe they
early on, they were taken it taken Vance.
And I think they just didn't put any ejection
because he totally overran the injection. We're
watching these races and it's like real
time crime. I call it a crime spike. And
then you get these crime spikes and everybody.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, listen, is that psychosis?
I have no idea. Not qualified to diagnose. Said
it certainly would be funny if it weren't sad.
And more importantly, it's extremely dangerous
because he has followers. And in all seriousness,
I don't understand how his family can't get him
some help and get him out of this endless loop.
It has been years now and Pillow has said I miss
my time with my family because I'm flying around
doing all this stuff I'm pouring. I think he
told me during our interview, 30 something
million into this stuff between lawyers and tech
and who knows what the hell else. At some point
you would think his family could get him some
help, but it does not seem to be happening.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: Producer Pat will join me. We are going
to zoom out and do five big picture takeaways from
the exit polls. The exit polls yesterday were
really interesting insofar as they asked people
about what do you think about the direction of the
country? How did people vote depending on that?
Who do you think won the 2020 election?
How did people vote? Depending on that,
you can probably guess. We're going to look
at takeaways from the exit polls. Secondly,
there is now increasingly the claim being made.
Ron DeSantis is the new Republican Party leader.
Trump didn't really endorse DeSantis.
He sort of begrudgingly did on Monday.
And DeSantis very much overperformed
and was reelected governor.
Meanwhile, many of the people Trump picked lost.
So we're going to talk about that. And then we
are also going to talk about where abortion
was on the ballot yesterday. It mostly saw
voter support. And that is not shocking if you
understand the polling data. But interesting to
see in a broader context all of those stories
and much more on today's bonus show. Folks,
this is the start. This is the start of what will
be an insane two years in American politics, which
hopefully doesn't end with the end of democracy.
Okay. Sign up at join pacman dot com. You'll get
the bonus show. You'll get commercial free audio
and video streams of the show. You'll be invited
to our next member only town hall. You can use
the brand new coupon code. 24 starts now. That's
two. Four starts now. No spaces, all lowercase
or caps. Doesn't matter. 24 starts now. Also,
make sure you're subscribed to our audio podcast.
It's on every podcasting platform. Whatever you
use, it's there. Make sure you're subscribed
on YouTube. We are getting started for what
is going to be a major undertaking over the
next two years. I'll see you on the bonus.